on fera tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir la
radicalisation dans la police et nomen
marginal ou menace réelle il y a quatre
mois c'était l'attentât de la préfecture
de police de paris depuis son six cas
ont été signalés aux services alors la
société de vigilance voulue par le
président de la république est elle
portait ses fruits et peut-on être
policier et musulmans dans le pays sont
d'être suspecté on en parle dans un
instant dans notre grand débat alors que
la commission denquête à l'assemblée a
fait un point d'étape sur les
dysfonctionnements dans l'attentât de la
préfecture de police
il refuse de lui serrer la main elle
déchire son discours c'est la guerre
totale entre donald trump et nancy
pelosi la présidente démocrate de la
chambre des représentants on va revenir
dans le détail sur la campagne
américaine avec nos invités donald trump
s'apprête à être acquitté dans son
procès en destitution fera un gros plan
aussi sur la surprise de cette première
primaire démocrate pitbull adjedj
le benjamin des candidats enfin notre
grand témoin ce soir est ancien
magistrat ancien député aussi il a
enquêté ici à l'assemblée sur des
attentats de paris de 2015 le bataclan
l'hyper cacher et et charlie hebdo
ils forment aujourd'hui les élus à
détecter les signaux la de
radicalisation jambes fennecs est avec
nous ce soir voilà vous savez tout est
axé vers n'oubliez pas c'est parti on
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir georges
fenech bonsoir on joue au mur y sommes
et merci d'être notre grand et moir vous
connaissez l'assemblée nationale comme
votre poche près de onze ans sur les
bancs de la droite vous avez notamment
présidé la commission d' enquête sur des
attentats de paris de 2015 magistrat
ancien juge d'instruction vous former
aujourd'hui les élus voulaient former à
la lutte contre la radicalisation va en
parler la radicalisation qui gagne
certains de mes anciens collègues chefs
socialistes la clasica san ans et
patrick mennucci le marseillais
le front républicain le front
républicain je vous en dirai un mot tout
à l'heure je le disais la radicalisation
qui gagne certains services publics on
en a parlé ici sur ce plateau à lcp
il ya eu des enquêtes parlementaires sur
des sujets et la police est elle
réellement menacé bonsoir jean michel
fauvergue la bienvenue à vous vous êtes
député la république en marche de seine
et marne
ancien patron du raid c'est vous qui
avait ordonné l'assaut sur l'hyper
cacher en 2015 coordonner cet assaut
vous siégez aujourd'hui dans cette
commission denquête il faut le rappeler
attaque au couteau quatre morts signé
michael harpon c'était le 3 octobre 2019
agents informatique qui travaillait au
coeur de la maison police la préfecture
de police de paris
vous nous direz ce que vous avez appris
dans cette commission qui a fait un
point d'étape aujourd'hui
sofiane à chati bonsoir bonjour et merci
d'être là vous êtes policier et vous
représentez l'unsa police dont vous êtes
le délégué national enfin m anna ce
qu'affiche bonsoir et bienvenue chez
vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris et
vous défendez un policier suspecté de
radicalisation suspendu et désarmé
depuis l' attaque de la préfecture c'est
un policier qui avait 16 ans de service
dans la police pour nous on dirait un
petit peu plus sur la manière dont il
vit les choses vous donne la parole
messieurs dans un instant celui qui nous
plante le décor à sa manière comme tous
les soirs vous savez c'est stéphane
stéphane blakowski sais j'ai bien
compris c'est parti
[Musique]
on sent myriam bonsoir messieurs bonsoir
stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce soir
alors laissez moi ma soirée je vous dis
immédiatement ce que j'ai cru comprendre
installez-vous en fait si j'ai bien
compris ça risque en fait ne pas être si
simple de mettre en place la société de
vigilance auquel aspire le président
macron alors vous souvenez c'était lors
de son discours dans la cour de la
patinoire de police après l assaut ciena
vous l'avez rappelé de quatre policiers
par un de leurs collègues radicaliser
donc ils avaient dit les institutions ne
parvenons pas à elle seule à faire face
à la montée de l'islamisme il faut que
chaque citoyen à participer
il a dit que chaque français doit être
vigilant donc il s'agit d'ouvrir l'oeil
savoir repérer à l'école au travail dans
les lieux de culte près de chez toi
les relâchements les déviations ces
petits gestes qui signale d'un
éloignement avec les lois et les valeurs
de la république
voilà dans son discours il faut quand
même dire que le président avait précisé
que cette vigilance ne devait pas tourné
au soupçon
bah oui myriam mais c'est ça justement
la difficulté c'est comment renforcer la
vigilance face à l'islamisme
sans non plus tomber dans un soupçon un
soupçon généralisé envers tous les
musulmans mal au départ on a quand même
compris qu'ils avaient comme un gros
gros problème de vigilance à la
préfecture de police un scellement qu'on
puisse dire il avait pas mal de vos
collègues de l'assassin avait remarqué
qu'il était radicalise et finalement on
n'avait jamais exclu du service
d'ailleurs le ministre lui même avait
dit après l'attentât il ya eu un
dysfonctionnement lors il ya eu un
dysfonctionnement qu'est ce qu'on fait
le premier ministre et balance une
mission pour savoir où est-ce que ça a
pêché donc là confie cette mission à
l'inspection des services de
renseignement et puis mi janvier il ya
quelques une série de mesures qui a été
pris pour renforcer un peu des mesures
pour lutter contre pour détecter la
radicalisation nous en gros on
centralise elle a déjà ici et puis on va
former plus de gens pour mener ces
entretiens mais est ce que ça sera
suffisant c'est ça aussi la question
donc on va chacun va pouvoir répondre le
plateau ce matin sur europe1 gamme et
bruno retailleau le patron des
républicains au sénat
et voilà ce en dépit non sur les
questions le premier ministre nous a dit
vais répondre à ce quadruple attentat
par deux enquêtes administratives
fichtre est-ce qu'on va effrayer les
terroristes est-ce qu'on va terroriser
les terroristes avec des enquêtes
administratives
rien ne s'est passé c'est à dire
heureusement à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez tiré aucune leçon n'a été
tirée leçon n'a été tirée
y at il eu une seule démission voilà
terroriser les terroristes la formule on
la connaît elle est signée charles
pasqua exact alors je fais un petit
rappel pour le contexte était donc en
mars 86 à une vague d'attentats qui
touche et la france et il a dit ça alors
que il a reconnu plus tard en fait c'est
d'ailleurs sur lcp avoir utilisé cette
formule tonitruante
parce qu'au début de l'enquêté ils
étaient perdus ministère de l'intérieur
il manquait deux de vision et donc y
lisait comme pour n'a plus de moyens le
solo moyen qui reste de le verbe dont il
avait utilisé cette formule donc je
pense pas que retailleau ai dit ça pour
masquer son impuissance face à la
question il voulait plutôt montré qu'il
était partisan de la fermeté
alors quand bruno retailleau dit qu'il
n'y a pas eu de démission à qui
pense-t-il à christophe castaner lemine
pas facile a pas réclamé sa tête
d'autres républicains avaient réclamé la
démission de castetner bon c'est à dire
à défaut de démission les hautes sphères
du ministère hong lei ou même de la de
l'administration policière est quand
même vu vraiment une vigilance accrue
castaner à rapper qui a eu 106
signalements qui ont été enregistrés
donc apparemment il ya quand même 80 qui
ont été écartés en dix ans n'a pas l'air
très sérieux et encore 44 qui sont sous
enquête et puis il ya eu des policiers
donc on en a ras qui on a retiré leurs
armes il ya eu neuf et a eu quatre qui
ont été suspendues par rapport à 150
mille policiers
ça paraît assez minime mais pourtant est
vrai qu'ils ont l'impression que cette
vigilance là justement elle entraîne un
soupçon à peu généralisés par rapport
aux musulmans qui bosse dans la police
était l'objet d'une enquête ce matin à
libé quatre pages donc il ya beaucoup de
lectures je vous laisse lire le titre
voyez c'est un témoignage certains de
nos collègues nous regardent maintenant
comme si on était des maghrébins avant
d'être des policiers alors bon je serais
pas étonné que si je vous dis que eric
ciotti n'est pas sur cette ligne de
libération un ca ou paranormal est
repris il était donc il préside la
commission d' enquête sur l'attentât
dans lequel siègent les députés
fauvergue et ce matin lui quand on met
ce que trop plus de vigilance ça va pas
être le soupçon généralisé des non au
contraire au moindre soupçon
il faut au contraire être en mesure de
prendre
sanction on écoute moi je demande que
lorsqu'il ya un doute sur une personne
eh bien il n'y ait pas de doutes pour la
société que la protection de la société
prime sur la protection de l'individu
donc il faudra peut-être qu'il y ait des
magistrats habilité au secret défense
qu'ils aient connaissance d'élément qui
permette de suspendre voire de radier
beaucoup plus facilement des agents ça
vaut pour la police mais ça vaut pour
d'autres services administrés voilà
quand eric ciotti plaident pour une
vigilance renforcée break ça va
renforcer aussi la suspicion au passage
ben alors ça s'est levé du débat on va
en parler moi juste on a peint avant je
voudrais rappeler que quand même le but
des islamistes dont de nos ennemis
c'est aussi une guerre psychologique et
convaincre des musulmans qui sont
rejetés en france qui n'ont pas leur
place dont gaffe quand même ne pas
ajouter de l'eau à leur moulin
merci stéphane ya beaucoup de choses
dans votre papier ce que ce soit avant
d'entrer dans le fond du sujet ce qui
s'est passé à la préfecture de police
que vous avez a pris puisque vous êtes
dans cette commission denquête et puis
cette société de vigilance quand vous
êtes policier musulman je voudrais un
premier tour de table sur ces chiffres
sont sic à 106 cas de signalement pour
radicalisation 80 déjà écarté 46 qui
font l'objet d'une enquête la moitié de
ces cas signalés dans la préfecture de
police de paris ça doit peut-être nous
intéresser à coiffer tonfas précisément
c'est marginal où on est face à une
menace endogène
vous verrez votre diagnostic d'abord la
première des choses à faire c'est de ces
ne pas céder à une espèce de panique de
généralisation à tout prix les faits
sont graves et sont très grave ils sont
même particulièrement grave et il faut
enquêter de manière froide et essayer
d'avoir des résultats et des résultats
factuelles sur un certain nombre de
choses et voir si les si les services
ont fonctionné et il faut pas demander
des démissions
c'est pas assez et des gens qui sont qui
ont des réflexes un peu particulier dès
qu'il se passe quelque chose on demande
les démissions des uns des autres fait
la pole et donc faire en infos on
acclame une tête
il faut voir il faut voir les choses
telles qu'elles ont été faites ici c'est
ça que sert une parler de ses pensées à
la préfecture de police met votre regard
vous sur la radicalisation
ce service public particulier qui
assurent la sécurité des français
est ce qu'il y a un vrai problème ou au
regard du nombre d'agents faut pas non
plus s'inquiéter ce que je voulais vous
dire moi c'est que le on est dans cette
radicalisation et date pas d'aujourd'hui
c'est pendant des décennies décennies ce
sas et ça c'est un style et ça s'est
instauré on arrive à une situation
particulière aujourd'hui sur lesquels on
on commence à ouvrir à peine les yeux
donc il faut travailler là dessus
maintenant il n'y a pas de raison de
penser que dans les rangs de la police
ou dans les rangs un jeune arbre ou dans
les rangs de l'armée
ça soit plus plus important qu'ailleurs
mais y'a pas de raison de penser non
plus mais ça ne soit pas présent ça
reste quand même une infime minorité
on parle d'une trentaine d'une
cinquantaine dans l'armée mais ça
concerne tous les corps administratif
il n'y a pas que la police dans l'armée
dit qu'on suit à peu près une
cinquantaine de militaires menace
endogène menace endogène partout je suis
administration pénitentiaire dans là
aussi dans les aéroports il a aussi cédé
minorité mais qui présente un réel
danger si on ne s'en préoccupe pas c'est
pour ça que la suite et de vigilance
c'est pas une société de délation c'est
une société précautionneuse c'est à dire
qu' il vaut mieux détecter très vite et
en amont quelqu'un qui peut présenter
une fragilité une perméabilité à la
radicalisation et le traité correctement
soit l'écarté d'un service sensible le
muté ailleurs ou alors éventuellement le
révoquer
si c'est un cas grave on va expliquer ce
qui se passe quand vous faites l'objet
d'un signalement savait pas forcément
dire que vous êtes radicalisé lors il ya
des enquêtes qui sont menées vous allez
nous expliquer ça dans le détail c'est
même l'inversé sur 106 signalement il
avait 80 quand j'ai été écarté comme pas
très font des dons va plutôt dire que
mais quand vous voyez que la moitié ces
signalements concernent la préfecture de
police de paris
ça pose le problème du fonctionnement de
la drpp ou 6 1
puisque c'est là que ça s'est passé
l'action la préfecture de police de
paris je pense jean michel faubert
peut-être ne peux pas trahir ce qui est
encore sous le sceau du secret mais
quand même eric ciotti a laissé entendre
j'ai compris d'ailleurs c'est moi ça ne
m'étonne pas un puisque c'était même à
une proposition que j'avais formulée
dans le cas de la commission des
requêtes de 2016 sur les attentats de
paris avec trente parlementaires
nous pensons que la direction du
renseignement de la préfecture de paris
doit être transférée entièrement à la
dsi qui est le véritable service
centralisateur et pilote la voiture de
police à un état dans l'état
d'ailleurs c'est ce drame est arrivé là
profitent aux de plus près il est
impensable qu'il puisse arriver à dgsi
parce qu'il ya des méthodes de criblage
en permanence qui sont d'un très haut
niveau par rapport à la commission d
enquête qui l'a pas fait grève voulait
pas lâcher ses prérogatives on est la
préfecture et on est comme ça en france
culturellement dans des silos il ya des
pouvoirs on s'accroche à son institution
mais l'intérêt général commande à mon
avis aujourd'hui de transférer toutes
les compétences de la drpp à la dgsi et
la scrt donc le renseignement
territoriale jeu suivant le voilà déjà
une première piste de solution je
termine ce tour de table sofia najati
aucun service public et épargnent et ça
existe bien sûr que ça existe il faut
appeler un chat un chat et effectivement
on a on à cette problématique dans
plusieurs services les aéroports les
services publics les services régaliens
l'armée les transports et la liste peut
être extrêmement longue
c'est un sujet sérieux sur lequel
effectivement nous devons traiter
beaucoup de force et détermination
cependant il faut
rappeler certaines certaines certains
constats certaines règles dans mon corps
la police nationale la police nationale
et républicaine n'a pas de couleur n'ya
pas de religion
le principe qui prévaut c'est celui de
réussite et de la neutralité et la lutte
contre la radicalisation l'intégrisme
religieux peut être un combat de tous
les jours
de tous les instants ça veut dire répété
avec force
on ressent que voit la vraie inquiétude
sur la la question d'être un policier
musulman dans cette société de la
vigilance que dit l'avocat vous vous
constatez le citoyen plutôt que ça
existe et puis on va partir ensuite à la
commission denquête même s'il faut être
vigilant aussi sur les éventuels
stigmatisation tout à fait d'abord il y
a une une attention particulière qui
prêtait à ce corps qui la police
nationale puisque par définition il est
fait pour défendre les français
donc c'est une c'est donc un service
régalien et je rejoins aussi ce qui a
été dit autour de sept de ses tables et
la vigilance qu'on prête à ce type de
corps de métier est davantage plus aiguë
que ce corps de métier fait pour pour
assurer la surveillance et la protection
tous les français donc je comprend à la
fois ses 7,7
cet attachement à ce que ce corps de
métier puisse incarner les valeurs
républicaines essentiel mais il faut
toujours garder à l'esprit que dans les
moments de crise il y a aussi des
moments de panique ou la raison
la raison peut parfois failli risque on
en est là ce matin on voit un quatre
pages dans libé donc je ce clip est très
sensible discrimination mais
il ya beaucoup de témoignages malgré
tout qu'ils témoignent fait que cette
vigilance elle commença très détention
ou des fins vous avez lu la phrase on
est considéré comme un maghrébin en un
policier ça pose c'est exactement la
contradiction de ce que vient de dire
allez-y puisqu'on y va parler nous un
tout petit peu de votre de votre client
alors le cas de mon client est assez
atypique puisque il ya eu en fait un
regard avant et un regard après les
attentats donc je sais le contexte de
crise qui a qui a été rappelé après un
attentat terrible dans quai a secoué les
services de la préfecture
donc par définition le soupçon et le
niveau de vigilance a été augmentée donc
ce soupçon est ce que ce niveau de
vigilance augmenté n'importe lequel des
signes dans tandis qu'ils sont faibles
sont interprétées subjectivement comme
un élément on va dire à charge
un élément qui montre qu' il y à une
potentielle radical votre client il a le
cas une clients spectre puis des armées
puis suspendu mon client il a été non
pas suspecté mais il y a
ce qu'on appelle un signalement qui
remontait à la suite de l'attentât ce
signalement d'anti llorente dit qu' il
ferait la prière on a versé aux dents
dans les pièces du débat cette
attestation de gens qui partageaient son
bureau qui disent tout à fait le
contraire c'est donc en fait il y a dans
ce dans ce cas précis qui celui de mon
client
des gens qui une seule personne en
l'occurrence qui dit il y a
éventuellement une prière donc on lui
reproche d'avoir pris gay cette
attestation disent le contraire de gens
qui partageaient son bureau mais ce que
ça révèle derrière c'est que le niveau
d'inquiétude est le manque de formation
si pour détecter ce que c'est un travail
d'une utilisation est tel que devant
cette crise ne peut plus faire la prière
sans être suspecté mais d'autres à peu
près à la faire je compte sur le plein
on va y revenir parce que là vous avez
paraît très très vite je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur la commission denquête eric
ciotti donc a tenu un point presse un
point d'étape sur les auditions la
manière dont cette commission au travail
et puis au fond ce qu'elle a appris à ce
stade c'est un sujet de nathalie gloire
le 3 octobre 2019
un informaticien q4 fonctionnaire à la
préfecture de police de paris
il s'agit de mickaël harpon suite à cet
événement une commission d'enquêté
lancée à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui les députés ont fait un
point d'étape problème pour le président
de cette commission
cette attaque n'aurait jamais dû avoir
lieu car sa hiérarchie aurait dû être
alertés par des signes de radicalisation
ce qui est clair c'est que michael
harpon n'aurait jamais dû rester compte
tenu des signes qu'il a émis extrêmement
inquiétant chacun individuellement ils
n'auraient jamais dû rester à la
préfecture de police
donc c'est une faillite collective dans
les procédures de sécurité d'un service
de renseignement autre constat les
dysfonctionnements au sein de la drpp la
direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police de paris
la culture de la vigilance vis-à-vis des
risques de vulnérabilité était absente
de la drv cette culture n'existait pas
elle le faisait partie n'est des
éléments de formation des agents
concernés ni même de l'environnement du
climat professionnel qui aurait dû être
celui d'un service de renseignement
depuis cet événement le nombre de
signalements et plus nombreux 46 ont été
déclarés les députés de la commission
denquête rendront leurs préconisations
au mois d'avril
comment précisément avez vous travaillé
jean michel vous auditionné à huis clos
parfois même sous le sceau du secret qui
avez vous vu les collègues de mecalac
harpon on a vu beaucoup de on a vu
beaucoup de personnes on a vu la
hiérarchie en et les chefs de service on
l'a vu oui on a vu les préfets et les
préfixes son fils et la préfecture de
police on a vu les collègues de travail
on a vu m'a encore aujourd'hui militaire
de syndicalistes on a vu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes vous avez
vu notamment un collègue exulté en
parlait sur les ondes rtl ce matin à
collègues de bureau de michael arnon
jeux wii qui expliquait d'après ce qu'a
expliqué le technicien des 607 secret
bon bah il l'a répété un mec
qu'il y avait des craintes qu'il y avait
des craintes n'ont pas de passage à
l'acte d'agression physique mais
notamment informatique de fuite
on a auditionné plusieurs plusieurs de
ses collègues de bureau et vous avez vu
que le rapport ensuite beaucoup eric
ciotti qui est président la commission
mais le rapporteur florent boudié a pris
la parole et va dans le même sens
évidemment florent boudié qui est de la
république un marché ricciotti et de l
erp ça nous a pas échappé
donc les les choses se rejoignent les
sujets se rejoignent là dessus et je
peux vous dire même que à l'intérieur de
cette commission qui est sur lesquels il
ya tous les courants politiques
il ya eu un consensus sur le constat est
effectivement le constat il est tel
qu'il a été tel qu'il a été décrit tel
que vous me posez la question il ya il
ya eu un problème il ya un vrai problème
à certains moments de de transmission de
l'information l'information revient
c'est la drpp un état dans l'état la
forteresse
je suis pas sûr ce pour l'instant sur
cette partie là la transmission de
l'information par le n + 1 immédiatement
au dessus de petits qui est avisé des
faits et qui ne transmet pas
d'information là on est quand même dans
le cadre du service dans lequel
travaillait
c'est un service sensible c'est un
service de renseignement qui travaillent
sur le terrorisme et effectivement ce le
celui qui passe à l'acte
quel harpon est à l'intérieur de ce
service il s'occupe du matériel
informatique s'occupa il n'est pas
opérationnel
mais il peut avoir accès à un certain
nombre de 1 certains nombres de
d'éléments qui se trouvent dans les
ordinands dur c'est qu'en fait il
indiqua qu'il était sourd donc il était
plutôt sympa or en temps et heure et
donc ses collègues se sentait mal de le
dénoncer un gars sympa avec un handicap
on est sur toute la difficulté trouve
qu'il ya pas vraiment si vous pensiez
vous mais si vous me le permettez on est
sur toute la difficulté de cette
problématique qui se pose à tous c'est à
dire qu'à un certain moment vous êtes
face à quelqu'un que vous connaissez
at il basculé at-il pas basculer son de
son attitude un peu différente
est ce que je le connais bien est ce qui
va à ses collègues de dessiner la
problématique c'est que à partir du
moment où ça bascule où ça bascule on
arrive à du meurtre en arrive à de
l'attentât et on n'est pas dans du droit
commun donc à un certain moment
peut-être que effectivement les manières
de faire qui ce qui se trouve dans le
code pénal qui se trouvent deux d'une
manière générale dans les textes
peut-être que les manières de faire ne
sont pas adaptés adapté pour cette
menace particulière qui est une menace
de grande ampleur et qui maintenant vise
à l'intérieur même des services un péril
de cette ampleur on revient sur les
procédures et sur les directions de
renseignement trop d'acteurs c'est ce
que vous disiez georges fenech
retailleau qu'on a entendu tout à leur
disais aussi au fond ni aucune démission
aux fouilles a pas eu de responsable qui
n'a pas fait son boulot
aujourd'hui voilà c'est ya des enquêtes
il ya des décisions pour rendre plus
opérationnel au fond les réhabilitations
secret défense et cta mais personne
n'est tombée est-ce que c'est normal
écoutez en 2015 quand ils les attentats
de paris a pas eu non plus de démissions
de qui que ce soit en réalité nous
n'étions pas prêts face à cette menace
qui était nouvelle personne ne pouvait
imaginer un bataclan
donc il a fallu revoir entièrement nos
doctrines donc c'était nos systèmes qui
n'était pas adapté si vous voulez s'agit
pas de réclamer des têtes pour des têtes
renault retail au n'est par exemple pas
de démission non plus non mais
l'imam de gonesse la démission
n'arrangera rien cette expulsion met
expulsion ça c'est autre chose c'est
autre chose mais ils en parlaient aussi
voilà bon je rappelle quand même qu'il a
eu sous des vous après les premiers
manifestation des gilets jaunes le
préfet michel delpuech la soute et à ce
moment là c'est on a vu arriver nouveau
préfet d'allemands donc il ya quand même
des décisions quelquefois qui sont
prises vous disiez classeur les leçons
ont été tirées selon vous moi je sais ce
stade moi je pense que l'inspection dont
on parlait tout à l'heure a déjà fait
des propositions fortes notamment tout
ce qui est secret habilitation secret
défense ira la dgsi c'est ce que dit
l'inspecteur et c'est apparemment la
commission denquête surveillante dans ce
sens et première formation ministre a
déjà pris des hybrides oui oui annonce
que c'est déjà une trimestre ça va
deuxième sommet ça va se mettre en place
vous avez la formation des agents à la
lecture à la grille de lecture des
signes de basculement ça si ça manque
est bonne et c'est bien on est on est
capable voilà c'est quoi ces formations
concrètement vous avez reçu ces types de
formation on est opérationnel sur sa non
pas du tout ma connaissance n'existe pas
de formation type ne bénéficions pas de
référent de référents radicalisation
donc on est encore loin de pouvoir de
pouvoir vraiment définir ce que c'est et
que l'arrêt des pratiques mois écouter
ces initiatives que j'ai prises avec mes
deux collègues nous le faisons en fait
on sillonne la france actuellement là
j'étais à lens la semaine dernière
lorsqu'il vint à châlons-en-champagne de
man somme hazebrouck on sillonne la
france pour rencontrer qui rencontrer
les élus est ce que cette vigilance en
fait c'est qui c'est les élus qui sont
au contact direct de leurs administrés
voyez-vous et donc de par notre
expertise et des éléments on leur
apporte des grilles de lecture
qu'est ce qu'un signe ou fois un signal
faible signal fort comment réagir qui a
formé quel est le retour
la circulaire du trans est rendu compte
par exemple la circulaire du 13 novembre
prise par christophe castaner qui
consistent les maires les élus qu'en
disent les maires la plupart des mères
ne connaissent pas la circulaire savent
pas que ils ont droit à une information
en retour des signalements qu'ils font
mais également deux fois par an ils
doivent être tenus informés de l'état de
la radicalisation dans leur commune une
fois signalé pour comprendre un peu
cette chaîne dont qui a manifestement
des efforts à faire sur la formation les
élus et également des déserts jantes
police une fois signalé qu est ce qui se
passe qui intervient pour vérifier
contrôler c'est le signalement est
fondée ou pas si voulez vous avez un
quant à 6 mg en effet il ya une chose
qui marche très bien c'est le numéro
vert qui est gérée par centre national
d'assistance et de prévention de la
radicalisation
les écoutants sont des policiers qui
sont fermés qui sont ou par non formés à
cette question là et c'est d'ailleurs un
numéro vert qui est surtout utilisé par
les familles qui sont désemparés par un
enfant qui tout à coup
n'écoute plus la musique des pouilles sa
chambre toute représentation humaine
refuse de serrer la main à une fille un
certain nombre de signaux comme ça à
partir de là quand le numéro vert est
actionnée il y à une transmission de
cette information évidemment au à la
préfecture il ya un groupe d de
dévaluation la radicalisation
départementale qui existent en liaison
avec les maires d'ailleurs et là il ya
des équipes mobiles qui vont dans les
familles qui cherchent à comprendre et
apporter des réponses se classe ensuite
quand c'est nécessaire et effectivement
peuvent trouver d'autres solutions et
michel faubert et ensuite on va parler
du malaise dans la police sur les lieux
dans les départements il ya des gets des
groupes des groupes particuliers dirigée
par le préfet dans lesquelles ce dans
laquelle siègent les services les
services de renseignement et tous les
cas le radicalisation et en particulier
des cas de radicalisation du soupçon de
radicalisation dans les services de
l'état ou dans les services déconcentrés
sont sont examinés examine et au niveau
national national tous les cas
maintenant qu'ils sont signalés à
l'intérieur des services de police
gendarmerie palanquée sont examinées par
la dige la scic est le chef de file de
la lutte contre le terrorisme
sofiane el fathi ben voilà il ya des
procédures nouvelles
il ya des cas de radicalisation parfois
et des signalements qui n'aboutissent
pas parce qu'ils sont pas fondées est-ce
que ça ça alimente un vrai malaise dans
la police quand on est musulman
est ce qu'il existe malaise on a vu
quatre pages de dans libération pour
vous montrer des témoignages je fais le
ramadan mais prière chaque jour est ce
que pour autant je suis radicaliser si
ça se trouve mes collègues ont peur de
moi même s'il ne me disent rien ça
existe ça c'est ça doit être extrêmement
posant j'aimerais vous répondre que ça
existe au sein de notre institution mais
ça existe également au sein de notre
société
donc on est humain on traverse cette
ambiance malsaine reconnaître parce
qu'une société de vigilance c'est aussi
un appel suspicion c'est ce sentiment
que mes collègues certains de mes
collègues effectivement subissent je
rappelle qu'une partie non négligeable
de policiers de gendarmes mais également
de militaires du rang qui veillent les
jours à la sécurité de nos compatriotes
et des fois au péril de leur vie sont
des personnes d'origines diverses et
variées de culture d'héritage pour
certains musulmane l'ordinateur d'état
ministère de l'intérieur a expliqué sur
les ondes de france inter qu'il n'y
avait pas de racisme anti musulman
dans la poule de 10 mio potes du tout de
sentiments antimusulmans la police qui a
lancé y'en a partout où la société soit
dans la police mais bon
est ce que vous êtes d'ailleurs il n'y a
pas de sentiment de racisme anti
musulman francs sentiments intimes vous
ne pouvez pas dire ça les maia est très
grande
il ya une très grande résilience aux
souffrances je ne pense pas que la
france et la corse définies comme ça
mais bon on va dire qu'il y à une
suspicion anti musulman alors alors
qu'elle existe
clay pas majoritaires elles existent
quand même nom mais pas le sentiment que
des paradis d'extrême droite ont
tendance à pointer du doigt les
musulmans al carrément tueur et les
choses par gap a vu des sondages parier
sur l'ognon nantais ce phénomène là faut
pas tomber dans l'amalgamé voir c'est ce
que je fais racisme anti musulman dans
la police j'aimerais vous entendre là
dessus est ce que est ce que vous avez
des exemples concrets
alors ce qui est ce qui est concret
c'est que il ya quand même une ambiance
malsaine dans nos rangs il faut le dire
il faut appeler un chat un chat
maintenant cette ambiance elle s'est
développée assez développé effectivement
certains de mes collègues qui serait
visiblement musulmans ou assimilés
subissent certaines formes de préjugés
et ses préjugés en fait vous voulez vous
les retrouver dans des comportements
dans des paroles dans des dents des
médias ont d'ailleurs mais également
dans des réseaux sociaux
et effectivement ça serait faire
l'économie du sujet de ne pas en parler
nous au sein de l'unsa police au sein du
syndicat que je représente
on défend tout le monde et on parle de
tout on ne censure pas à mon avis il
faut en parler pour pouvoir trouver des
éléments bien pédagogie afin
effectivement de réduire ce sentiment
pour terminer sur sur cette question là
j'imagine que votre client donc a fait
appel à vous pour faire valoir ses
droits
il estime qu' il a été suspendu à tort a
les armes et à tort que lui est il
arrivé préciser les mesures de
suspension sont par définition près
disciplinaire et ne revêtent pas un
caractère de sanction disciplinaire
toutefois je rejoins ce que vous avez
dit qu'ils fondamental dans nos sociétés
actuelles c'est que il y à un manque de
compréhension du phénomène de l'islam
qui est totalement différente du
phénomène de la radicalisation et ce
manque de pédagogie ce manque
d'information dans un appareil
sécuritaire important père peut peut
conduire à des décisions qui comme dans
le cas de mon client
des décisions qui sont regrettables
après pour les autres cas je ligne je
les ignore je ne connais pas qu'elle ait
calé quelle est la nature de ces
dossiers mais ce que je peux dire c'est
que quand vous avez dans une société un
1-1 à degré de méconnaissance de ce que
c'est vraiment le phénomène de
radicalisation doublée d'une vigilance
qui ne s'exerce pas sur des éléments
stratégiques
là vous pouvez commettre des erreurs
mais c'est pas seulement les erreurs
qu'il ne faut pas aller andreu il faut
pas qu'on avance syndicalisation et
fondamentalisme par exo la refête mandat
qu'il ya un pourcentage m avec
terrorisme bien ma vie davantage avait
totalement méconnu assurant du coup
c'est que sur les radicaliser 30 % sont
des converties alors convertis vous vous
donnez on est sur une ligne de crête
habilité bien sûr c'est difficile c'est
un projet un problème sociétal en ce
moment
on est impacté par cette violence là
aussi j'ai le mot de la fin je voudrais
juste juste rappeler que dans les
victimes de charlie il y à il y avait un
de nos collègues
le policier qui était qui était musulman
qui est des pratiquants musulmans et les
musulmans sont les premières et qui
s'est fait aux résidants situés sur le
passé par c'est par ces islamistes ces
extrémistes qui se fait tuer sur l'autre
autour merci on s'arrête là messieurs on
va ouvrir à présent georges fenech vous
restez avec nous une page retraite
figurez vous que tous les jours jusqu'au
municipal c'est elsa monde à gaza qui
est plus pour nous le débat
parlementaire retraite à points pour un
point retraite s'est tout de suite allé
changement de sujet alsace est pas
simple on y va toute la semaine les
députés passent en revue les milliers
d'amendements on a plus de 20000 en
commission spéciale
aujourd'hui c'est la question sensible
des enseignants qui s'est invité dans le
débat
exactement un myriam y aura la question
des policiers également mais c'étaient
les enseignants ce matin dans l'article
1 c'est un article qui donne les grands
principes de la réforme et qui tente de
rassurer et bien ceux qui avaient
beaucoup à y perdre
les enseignants depuis qu'on connaît un
petit peu les contours du nouveau
système ils ont sorti la calculatrice et
ils n'ont pas été très content du
résultat
pourquoi bien parce que leur retraite
elle sera calculée sur l'ensemble de la
carrière et plus les six derniers mois
et même si les primes elles rentrent
dans le calcul est bien et eux ils en
ont peu bref des centaines d'euros en
moins et donc le gouvernement a voulu
rassurer
il a rassuré dans cet article un par un
alinéa qui promet aux enseignants une
loi de programmation avec des mécanismes
de revalorisation alors qu'est-ce qui
serait nous dise ce point précisément
sur les enseignants parce qu'on sait que
le conseil d'état a déjà tiquer là
dessus exactement il a rendu son avis et
c'est le point 29
on va le traduire en français le plus
simple possible sans trahir le sens le
conseil d'état dit et bien une loi ne
peut pas renvoyer à une autre loi qui
n'existe pas après c'est un peu une
question d'interprétation
au mieux ça n'engage à rien au pire
c'est inconstitutionnel
et bien c'est de cela dont les
oppositions voulu parler en commission
écouter eric coquerel pour les insoumis
et boris vallot pour les socialistes ce
que dit le conseil d'état est quand même
assez clair et pour
pour cause parce qu'en réalité ce que
vous faites c'est que vous nous faites
voter quelque chose en prévision d'une
loi dont elle-même connaîtront pas le
contenu et sur lequel forêt à l'avance
nous les enseignants quand vous fassent
confiance groupe socialiste apparentés
ne peut que s'émouvoir de ce tour de
passe-passe qui finira par rattraper le
gouvernement et une fille née l'ensemble
des enseignants qui espèrent des
promesses qui ont été faites
même si l'on doute fortement tout ça est
bien c'est de la mauvaise foi pour
olivier vers ans est un ancien
socialiste passé à la république en
marche écouter gâcher ce progrès social
que je ne saurais voir
c'est ça depuis hier c'est ça depuis
avant-hier c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'il n'avait pas une avancée sociale
forte marquante dans texte vous martelez
que c'est pas bon que ça marchera jamais
que ça n'arrivera pas je vous dire un
truc moi en cinq ans de mandat
socialiste j'aurais bien aimé qu'on
revalorise les profs j'aurais adoré voté
un amendement qui disait qu'on allait re
valoriser les propres donc la majorité a
adopté la rédaction à la quand même
sorti ces dispositions de l'article 20
pour les mettre dans un article 1 bis
peut-être pour se protéger en cas de
problème constitutionnel
merci elsa qui nous plonge dans ce débat
retraite cette commission spéciale c'est
un peu le talon d'achille de cette
réforme les enseignants le conseil
d'état l'a déjà l'a déjà dit il ya un
risque juridique vous promettez une
révélation mais vous risquez d'être
tapés par le conseil je suis m
je suis pas sûr le conseil d'état là
dessus a été assez rassurant ses parents
je pense que si l'âme si la méthode est
et est mise en cause pour autant elle
est peinte anticonstitutionnelle et ce
débat là
si vous permettez moi je les à la maison
parce que j'ai un j'ai un beau fils qui
est enseignant es une fille qui est
enseignant et bien du mal à expliquer
effectivement elle est dur à expliquer
cette cette loi sur les retraites
mais les retraités actuels c'est dur
aussi a expliqué hé bien les enseignants
on s'engage ne verront pas leurs
pensions baissent engagement et être
l'invité parce que effectivement savas
calculé sur l'ensemble de donc c'est
donc normalement si tout se passe bien
et toujours bien parti en tout cas on a
encore quelques semaines devant nous
pour lui pour vérifier tout cela merci
messieurs merci elsa vous restez avec
nous georges fenech ont pas parlé d'un
tout autre sujet est-ce qu'il est plus
léger
donald trump georges n'a rien en tout
cas on va d'abord faire un gros plan
dans cette campagne américaine sur la
surprise la surprise de la première
primaire démocrate connaissez-vous pitt
boutet djedj j'ai réussi à le dire 38
ans ancien maire d'une ville de lyndiane
à au nord-est du pays des jeunes
il est gay et il est vainqueur du caucus
dans l'iowa selon les derniers décomptes
son portrait avec ahmed taya lebouc et
janis et john gobbi et ouled ziane
même si donald trump a du mal à
prononcer son nom retenez le bien piteux
boutel djedj c'est l'homme qui monte
la révélation démocrate de cette
campagne déjouant les pronostics dans la
primaire présidentielle démocrate de
l'iowa pif gadget ge est arrivé en tête
selon les résultats partiels légèrement
devant bernie sanders est largement
devant joe biden les deux favoris à
l'investiture du parti à seulement 38
ans pitt bouteldja des candidats à la
primaire démocrate ici ils sillonnent
l'état du new hampshire
une mission séduire les électeurs avec
un programme centriste sa cible donald
trump
je me présente pour être le président
qui pourra être debout sur les débris
le jour où la présidence trump sera
enfin derrière nous pour ramasser les
morceaux et nous guider vers un avenir
où nous ferons face ensemble parce que
la seule façon de le faire c'est de le
faire ensemble
cet ancien maire d'une petite ville dans
l'indiana détonne parmi des candidats
deux fois plus âgé
diplômé d'harvard cet ancien analyste
des renseignements par le bi langues
il est le fils d'un immigré venu de
malte images inédites un couple
homosexuel qui ne se cache pas et qui
brigue la maison blanche clip ou tel
djedj n'hésite pas à s'afficher devant
les caméras avec son mari son
orientation sexuelle
elle semble avoir peu d'impact sur le
choix des électeurs qu'ils coûtaient
jazz
il est un peu le pont entre deux
amériques et ça se voit dans son style
dans son projet de société et dans sa
vie personnelle c'est à la fois
quelqu'un qui a fait harvard qui vient
de la classe moyenne qui est un vétéran
de la guerre d'afghanistan qui est
chrétien qui revendique sa foi donc ça
c'est l'américain peu classique et puis
par ailleurs il s'est marié avec son
compagnon il y a quelques mois il est
ouvertement gay donc et puis il a un
discours d'ouverture sur l'accès à
l'avortement
sur les questions de société mais de
manière toujours modérée on va dire
c'est à dire comme s'ils voulaient
vraiment faire le pont entre deux
amériques et c'est parfois ce qui lui
est reproché
un pari déjà gagné s'imposer comme
candidat incontournable dans la course à
la maison blanche
mais la route reste longue pour pitbull
de judge en juillet le vainqueur de la
primaire sera intronisé les américains
désignent auront eu leur président le 3
novembre prochain
bienvenue sur ce plateau roland lescure
vous êtes député la république en marge
des français d'amérique du nord vous
connaissez très bien ce continent vous
habitez en partie avec votre famille au
canada même si vous siégez ici même à
l'assemblée bonsoir françois durpaire au
sort et merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
historien spécialiste des états unis
vous viendrez d'ailleurs régulièrement
de raconter les épisodes haletants de
cette campagne américaine on commence
par pete footage la surprise en tout cas
à l'heure où on se parle il est en tête
des votes du caucus de l'iowa parlez
nous de lui
ça vous a surpris françois il arrive en
tête
non non on va pas faire le malin mais
c'était pas très surprenant s'ils ont
regardé ce qui se passait dans les
derniers jours de la campagne vous savez
il ya un stratège démocrate qui dit
comment on fait pour gagner dans l'iowa
on s'organise on s'organise et après
fait le show et il a réussi à organiser
les choses et surtout à faire le show
c'est lui qui remplissait le plus de
monde dans ses meetings tout à la fin
alors évidemment aujourd'hui vous
rappeler en janvier 2008 on expliquer
aux gens comment ça se prononce barack
obama envoie même chose autour de beauté
djedj comment ça se prononce bouteilles
y avait pas grand chose à dire et il
disait jo l'endormi thunders le chou
pocahontas ça c'est pour les abattoirs
année ses origines amérindiennes supposé
et pour des jets il avait pas trop grand
chose à dire s'était dit bien c'est en
tout cas il a même fait des petits
badges
on peut même voir ça parce que
il y a une difficulté a prononcé cette
ce nom d'origine maltaise et il s'en est
amusé ce jeune candidat avec même des
petits autocollants pour expliquer
comment ça se prononce roland lescure on
pense évidemment un certain emmanuel
macron 38 ans voici vous ai pensé et 39
ans quand il sera élu s'il est élu ça
rappelle quelques souvenirs dont il ya
des parallèles évidents lier ça a été
dit d'ailleurs à son parcours personnel
à son éducation il parle lui lang 8 fait
notamment très bien le français
d'ailleurs vous souvenez que quand notre
dame à brûler il a fait une intervention
assez émouvante et en français parfait
pour témoigner de sa solidarité avec la
france donc c'est vrai qu'il ya des
parallèles évidents il ya aussi des
choses très différentes très américaine
c'est un vétéran de l'afghanistan
évidemment ça ça fait partie des plus on
peut dire dans l'histoire dans ce qu'on
appelle le storytelling d'un candidat
américain y en a eu beaucoup d'eau dans
le passé on pense évidemment à john
mccain est un candidat homosexuel il
faut le dire et c'est le premier en tout
cas avait réaffirmé et eon mari
d'ailleurs qui est plutôt un atout parce
qu'il est assez sympa assez
show-business aussi et et on a eu une
histoire assez marrante hier une petite
image d'une électrice qui avaient voté
pour lui parce qu'elle ne trouvait plus
ben justement sans vous l'avez on l'a
allez on regarde ce n'était pas arranger
ça écoutons
[Musique]
donc c'est pas gagné loin de là non
c'est pas gagné je pense là la vraie
nouvelle en fait du scot honda et aux as
et joe biden s'est effondré parce qu'il
était quand même le candidat de
l'établissment je dirais petite vieille
c'est un peu le plan b de l'établissment
donc je pense que l'establishment
démocrate est prêt à soutenir surtout si
à dubaï ne s'effondre et le gagnant qui
est absent du scrutin la ja c'est mike
bloomberg
parce qu'il a dit je fais l'impasse sur
les premières primaires je serai là pour
le fameux super mardyck et le gros
rendez-vous des primaires début février
ancien maire de new york il ya donc mais
non c'est loin d'être gagné
c'est vrai qu'obama avait gagné lounge
en 2008 donc c'est un premier signe mais
on sait bien que la loi c'est tout petit
alors justement les enseignements de
cette première des primaires démocrates
outre la jeunesse des dettes alors d'un
effectivement premiers renseignements
bouter diète existait effectivement
attention à ne pas le mettre de côté
complètement il gagne dans l'iowa mais
il peut gagner ailleurs c'est tout à
fait possible
on avait dit jamais un noir serai
président des états unis à la veille de
l'élection on parlait du bradley effect
qui était le fait que les électeurs du
zoo oui on va voter pour un noir mais
dans le secret de l'isoloir
n'allez pas voter pour lui donc il en
est peut-être de même pour un homosexuel
une personne revendiqué au bout de 15
ans est en tout cas l'historien il est
prudent et il peut pas dire c'est
impossible en tout cas de la gagne et
son vrai talon d'achille c'est pas son
homosexualité
c'est le fait qu'il est inconnu qu'il
est inconnu dans le sud des états unis
qu'il est inconnu dans le sud ouest
et quand les afro américains ne le
connaissent pas que les hispaniques ne
le connaissent pas donc ça sera très
difficile d'aller gagner des états comme
la caroline du sud par exemple deuxième
enseignement
la vraie surprise le rat gagnant c'est
bernie sanders
pourquoi parce que bernie sanders
d'abord il peut revendiquer le vote
populaire beaucoup de gens voter pour
lui et il est dans cette position de
force parce que effectivement il a mis
très très loin son concurrent principal
le modéré joe biden parce que joe biden
il était en tête des sondages nationaux
et on vous disait que pendant des mois
ça sert à rien les attentats du sondage
national
il faut être sur le terrain ce qu'on
appelle le guen games à être vraiment
jouer sur le terrain et ça il n'a pas su
le faire
binder mais j'aimerais peut-être des uns
et les autres mais il est en tête dans
les intentions de vote dans le new
hampshire
on se reverra la semaine prochaine c'est
mardi va-t-il gagner dans le nevada où
les syndicats sont très importants il
est tout à fait possible qui viennent ça
serait une passe de 3,6 under sera porté
les trois états donc sanders est en
train de s'installer effectivement
bloomberg qui pour l'instant a fait le
choix de ne pas rentrer dans cette
campagne de rentrer dans la campagne
pendant le super tuesday
c'est tout à fait positif pour lui parce
qu'il peut se dire il ya deux atouts le
modéré weiden il est très loin je peux
prendre sa place saunders peut faire un
peu peur à l'establishment et puis
surtout quel bazar
quel bazar donc sa stratégie politique
elle est plutôt mauvaise à bloomberg
parce qu'il faut respecter la démocratie
et être il était aussi donald trump
milliardaire mais il était allé dans
l'iowa fait campagne dès le début là il
dit bon je fais campagne qu'après alors
là il a de la chance parce que c'est un
bazar terrible et puis évidemment les
républicains qu'est ce qu'ils disent ils
disent vous voulez confié la maison
blanche pas des gens qui sont même pas
capables d'organiser une primaire dans
un état de trois minutes alors qu'on en
parle un peu parce que évidemment ça
fait le jeu dans ce fiasco technique de
cette primaire démocrate ça fait le le
jeu de donald trump
rien ne fonctionne exactement lorsque
comme lorsqu'il dirigeait le pays voilà
ce 4 août et le président américain la
seule personne qui peut revendiquer une
très grande victoire dans l'iowa
la nuit dernière c'est moi lapin pour
raisons il a n'a pas tort c'est à dire
qu'il y avait la même je pense lui ou un
de ses seins de son directeur de
campagne a dit vous voulez vraiment
confié le système de sécurité sociale
donc à mes obamacare à des gens qui
savent pas oublier une primaire cent
soixante deux mille électeurs donc c'est
vrai que c'est un désastre
la campagne va être longue il va se
passer plein de choses d'ici là ils ont
intérêt à régler ses problèmes
techniques pour un poids sur un souvient
de l'élection des last reuze de george
bush la première avec les machines
électorales qui fonctionne et les
français du nord vivent t-il la
gouvernance la présidence trappe
dans l'ensemble ils sont pas très fan du
président entre hommes d'abord ils ont
eu peur parce qu'il y avait des enjeux y
compris même de visas non qu'ils avaient
peur qu éventuellement leur présence sur
le territoire sur un des plus compliqués
ensuite c'est pas une image d'épinal il
ya pas mal de français qui travaillent
dans le pinard aux états unis sierre qui
importe qui vendent qui distribue et
vous savez qu'il ya eu des taxes et
droits à l'importation sur le vin qui
ont frappé de manière assez forte
puis bon moi je fais toujours mon petit
sondage quand je vais voir les français
qui vivent là bas il y en a beaucoup qui
votent en fait parce qu'ils sont aussi
américains alors ils ont deux candidats
c'est intéressant beauty djedj et warren
il ya un certain nombre elizabeth warren
effectivement pocahontas dans les dires
de tram mais que quelqu'un d'abord c'est
intéressant elle est conseillée par des
français il ya trois économistes
français assez connus qui sont
déconseillés très proche d'elizabeth
warren le choix des français sur le
terrain plutôt que trump s'est
effectivement aux arènes ou du dieu des
fennecs le style trump il vous intéresse
il est très populaire et jamais été
aussi populaire que pendant cette
période actuelle les résultats
économiques sont bons en général ça fait
la réélection
qu'en pensez vous écoutez moi j'ai un
peu suivi le discours de l'union tout le
monde
il a fait son plaidoyer pro domo à
savoir jamais l'amérique s'est porté
aussi bien que depuis que je suis là en
réalité et vous allez voir les choses
vont encore s'améliorer at il dit mais
la réalité c'est qu'il a raison sur plan
économique les amériques américaines
sont jamais aussi bien portés pas que
tout va bien effectivement aux états
unis mais il y à un renouveau économique
sur le plan international on peut quand
même considérer qu'il n'a pas tout faux
malgré ces réactions un peu excentrique
par moments
donc moi la question que j'aimerais
poser est-ce qu'il est est ce qu'il est
et ce qu'il est vraiment battable
aujourd'hui va dire parce qu'il est
battable voir les bataves c'est celle à
100 en tout cas c'est la semaine la
meilleure pour dos d'un train de toute
sa présidence
c'est un conte et 49% il n'a jamais été
il est au dessus de ce qui faisait au
moment de sa première élection
et moi j'ai étudié dans le cas d'un
ouvrage tous les discours sur l'état de
l'union et j'ai jamais vu ce type de
discours sur l'état de l'union dans un
discours sur l'état du monde c'est
généralement unités et consensus même
pour donald trump on avait dit du
dernier si on ne sait pas que c'est
donald trump
on peut penser que c'est n'importe
quelle république à lille sont faits le
là pour ça qu'ils nous regardent un
discours sur l'état de l'union
chaque année les villans bilan de
l'année et trace des perspectives pour
l'année qui vient devant le congrès
c'est un grand moment des institutions
américaines et c'est généralement
l'occasion de faire quelque chose de
trans partisan d'aller chercher les
démocrates quand on est républicain et
les républicains quand on est démocrate
là on avait un discours provocant vente
art théâtral partisans flamboyant
extravagant à certains moments et le
pire pour ses adversaires c'est ce que
vous venez de dire c'est qu'il peut se
le permettre il peut se le permettre
parce que parce que aujourd'hui deux
tiers des américains disent l'économie
va bien on le doit à donald trump c'est
exactement 63% que sur la politique
étrangère 52% des américains vous voyez
c'est pas seulement les républicains
disent il a très bien géré
la question iranienne sur la politique
étrangère qu'on est d'accord quand on
est américain avec les accords
commerciaux mixx canada et récemment
chine
alors évidemment et qu'on est d'accord
aussi avec vous savez qu'il a été
acquitté dans quelques heures
ah oui hier va bénéficier bon on va pas
déflorer ce qu'on va dire mais il va
bénéficier de ce qu avait bénéficié
voudra plaidé qu'une tonne 72 % de
popularité
l'effet acquittement un président
renforcer sur la destitution c'est une
la logique institutionnelle
il va être acquitté même si on la prend
à l'instant mitt romney va compte d'un
voté contre
le républicain n'a voté contre oui mais
si vous savez que c'était mitt romney
étaient les uns des deux républicain à
ne pas accepter les témoins donc c'était
le procès sans témoin voilà mitt romney
avait déjà montré qu'il était peu ce qui
est important c'est de dire que tous les
républicains tous les bons bilans et
voilà il se prépare à son acquittement
est exactement ça a renforcé le camp le
camp républicain
les démocrates là pour l'instant et bien
son foyer très déprimés ils ont gagné
quasiment tout les élections partielles
ils ont un président qui a jamais
dépassé 50% de popularité est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui au moment où ils
en parlent ils sont très pessimistes sur
leurs chances d'élection
alors justement pessimiste que ils en
sont finalement à faire des gestes
symboliques
c'est l'autre image du jour ce n était
jamais vu à nancy pelosi qui déchire un
ostensiblement le discours de donald
trump qui un peu plus tôt avait refusé
de lui serrer la main
ils en sont là les démocrates mais en
fait c'est une réponse que j'ai trouvé
moi c'est excellent de la bergère au
berger et cirque ils l'ignorent on lui
serrerait pas la main elle l'avait
applaudi de manière un peu ironique au
dernier discours de l'état de l'union la
haye déchire son discours est bon là
reçus ici vous c'est bien joué mais ça
donne le sentiment qu'ils n'ont plus que
les symboles non moi je pense que
il a tord grandes chances d'être réélu
parce que vous le disiez un cv clinton
qu'ils aient c'est l'économie espèce de
vidéo mais si economy stupid l'économie
américaine va bien les etats unis sont
extrêmement divisée et on sait bien tout
ce que cette élection va jouer dans
quelques états les états de la ceinture
ou yella du nord-est où on a bien vu que
en 2016 il l'avait emporté fortement
parce que les femmes avaient voté pour
lui et parce que les afro américains les
noirs n'avaient pas voté pour lui en
il a quand même perdu les élections de
moyen terme à le congrès majoritairement
démocrate en partie à ce que les femmes
n'ont pas voté pour lui et on a deux
candidats potentiels démocrates en tout
cas elizabeth warren je pense mais aussi
puis de beauty jack qui très très
populaire parmi les femmes qui peut
faire la différence donc on sait bien
que l'élection américaine c'est une
macro élections mais c'est aussi une
toute petit micro élections dans
quelques états qui représente vraiment
des états très important donc l'histoire
n'est pas déjà écrite
non je pense pas je pense qu'il ya un
grand soir oui alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que celui qui gagne
l'iowa y donne un signe pour ses fameux
état de la rust belt en disant si je
gagne la yuuwaa sais que je peux gagner
peut-être le oui ce qu'enseigne michigan
alors ça ça peut paraître technique pc
de la géographie américaine c'est ce qui
a permis à a donné un train de
l'emporter en allant gagner des états de
gauche d etat avec l'ouvrier blanc et
donc vous ai déjà dit il dit moi je peux
gagner ces états le paradoxe est qu
l'iowa sera sans doute perdue par les
démocrates et gagné par les républicains
mais mais ça peut être beaucoup plus
complexe que ça ça peut être une autre
carte électorale
ça peut être dans un mouchoir de poche
est pour l'instant donald trump il peut
aussi peut-être compter sur un vote
populaire plus important tout cas
d'élection elle est évidemment pas joué
c'est donald trump et ça sera très
différent d'avoir un thunder face à lui
sylla sanders face à lui sera obligé
d'être à contre nature
il va pas être donnée à 39 où il va dire
d'ailleurs il a commencé à l'appeler
comme ça
sanders le fou c'est le fou et donc moi
je serais le président tout à fait
modéré tout à fait pacifique
il veut effacer tous et rana trois ans
et il va essayer d'être raisonnable
parce que là il aura intérêt parce que
la bonne nouvelle pour lui c'est qu'il
fait plutôt très bien en ce moment chez
les indépendants 1 se vend
entre mou de l'électorat américain et
cet électorat là va beaucoup compter
merci messieurs on y voit beaucoup plus
clair sur cette campagne
ça fait rêver quand même quand on voit
qu'un président à la fin de son mandat
est plus populaire qu'au début ça
n'arrive jamais sous la vème république
mais l'état de grâce aux des roues et
telus chirac a été réélue sa
cohabitation mitterrand la pression
habitations fidèles étaient en
cohabitation obama était en copie d'acte
est long mais tort ça donne des idées le
retour de la comique à leurs mots d'un
ciel est extrêmement choqué par
l'attitude de les ententes démocrates
qui étaient shihri le discours de
l'union
c'est tellement symbolique ce discours
de l'union et je crois que les équipes
de trump ont bien réagi en disant elle a
déchiré tous ceux que j'ai citées ces
valeureux américains etc
je trouve que c'est un crime de lèse
union je ne sais pas institutionnelle en
tout cas ça ne grandit pas les
démocrates je pense que ça bénéficie
davantage à donald trump
allez merci pour ce coup de galles
contre la poignée de main mais c'est du
train spécial est juste et refusé de
l'accueillir
donc si on est dans la cour de
récréation peut dire la première avoir
attaqué ce qui passe dans la chronique
de valérie brochure que vous attendez
tous elle est ou ce soir valérie on
parle beaucoup des retraites mais on
parle aussi du réchauffement climatique
ici à l'assemblée nationale j'ai suivi
pour vous l'audition du fondateur du
geiq je vais vous résumer tout cela tout
de suite en plateau
[Musique]
c'est valérie brochard pour sa journée à
l'assemblée je vous conseille de
l'écouter elle est piquante valérie
alors jean jouzel était auditionné par
la commission des affaires étrangères
absolument au miriam 1h30 face aux
députés et je vais vous demander d'être
tous très très fort un sur le plateau ce
soir car les nouvelles du climat ne sont
pas bonnes mais alors pas bonne du tout
2010neuf été la deuxième année la plus
chaude que nous ayons connu depuis 150
ans on est de façon très claire sur des
trajectoires de 3 degrés dans la au
moins dans la deuxième partie de ce
siècle
je dirais que c'est trop vis-à-vis des
jeunes c'est égoïste la part de nos
générations vis à vis des jeunes
d'aujourd'hui c'est très clair même si
nous nous arrêtons 10 de respirer de
rien faire et bien nous allons dans le
mur collectivement il faut bien se
rendre compte de ça bon bah oui c'est
terrible c'est terry mais allons voir
peut-être du côté des élus qui seront
peut-être un petit peu plus optimistes
nous croyons que c'est perdu et que le
changement climatique est commencé c'est
perdu et rien ne va s'arranger dans ce
domaine bon bien ce très pessimiste mais
évidemment chaque mais non parce que les
députés vous le savez on se mit à jean
jouzel des des outils des solutions jean
luc mélenchon a évoqué par exemple la
règle verte et puis un peu plus tard mme
sa fin la bid lui voulait s'attaquer à
l'industrie textile on écoute un rapport
des nations unies estiment qu'il faut
7500 litres d'eau pour fabriquer un jean
un jeans est l'équivalent de l'obuts par
un être humain pendant sept ans sans
oublier le pétrole matières premières de
du pauliste r&d essentielle à la
production de masse de textile donc
pourriez-vous nous dire messieurs je
vous ai pourquoi ce levier n'est pas une
priorité dans les différents rapports du
giec et oui pourquoi et oui pour sauver
le climat a bien fini
allez jean tout simplement ça fait
partie des idées des bonnes idées bien
sûr mais la bonne réponse pour le
fondateur du gic sera plutôt européenne
voire mondiale il attend beaucoup de la
prochaine cup qui se débrouillent
déroulera à glasgow
merci valérie sur le climat vous serez
sûrement jugé nous serons sûrement joué
là-dessus par nos enfants merci
messieurs d'être passé sur le plateau de
lcp c'est la fin de cette émission
allemand
[Musique]